samuel patty a été pris pour cible au
fond pour avoir porté les valeurs de la
république
mercredi prochain la nation lui rendra
hommage sans attendre je tiens au nom du
sénat et comme des millions de français
à exprimer notre compassion et notre
soutien à la famille de sa mère pattie à
ses proches ainsi qu'à ses collègues et
aux élèves du collège du bois donne où
il enseignait comme aux habitants et aux
élus de conflans sainte honorine et
d'errani je tiens également assuré de
notre solidarité du pr soutient
l'ensemble de la communauté enseignante
de notre pays
profondément affecté la république est
en danger
comme elle l'a rarement été cet acte
odieux vient après tant d'autres actes
une fois encore il nous faut rester uni
et déterminé
déterminés à ne plus rien céder jamais
nulle part j'entends que nous sommes à
un tournant
quel est donc ce tournant tuer des
enfants à toulouse
n'était-ce pas déjà un tournant
assassiner des journalistes n'était-ce
pas un tournant et ganges et un prêtre
dans son église tué un policier et sa
conjointe à leur domicile
à chaque fois c'était un tournant est-ce
que nous ne tournons pas sur nous mêmes
nous avons été charlie nous nous sommes
rassemblés pour crier notre indignation
nous avons clamé avec force les valeurs
de la république
nous avons fait la promesse que l'avenir
ne ressemblerait plus au passé que la
république réagir et avec détermination
et pourtant deux présents ressemble ou
pas
là encore déclaration mobilisation
engagements nos parlementaires qui avons
déjà produit de très nombreux rapports
sur ce sujet nous devons contribuer à
une réponse ferme de la république à la
hauteur du danger
nous le devons aussi à la mémoire de ce
mail pâtit nous ne devrons plus accepter
d'accommodement la laïcité pleine et
entière l'état de droit partout et pour
tous monsieur le garde des sceaux mes
chers collègues je vous invite à
observer un moment de recueillement en
la mémoire de sommeil petit mais aussi
pour affirmer notre attachement dans
notre diversité aux valeurs de la règle
je vous remercie